so liebe Leute ungewöhnliche Situationen
erfordern ungewöhnliche Maßnahmen ich
melde mich hier aus San Franzisco bin
ich eingeladen worden von Disney um mal
den Leuten von Pixa auf die Finger zu
schauen die gerade cars2 fertig stellen
der ja Ende Juli bei uns ins Kino kommt
und jetzt bin ich auf der Golden Gate
Bridge so sieht der Blick nach oben
entlang eines pilers aus und achtung
jetzt nicht nicht schwindelfreie so
sieht der Blick nach unten ins Wasser
aus und die ungewöhnliche Situation ja
das ist ein Thema was wir in allen
Kommentaren unterm Kanal in Video unter
den Videos und so weiter seht Kronk
Kronk Kronk so wie helfe ich mir selbst
ich sage es euch das kleine Problem ist
Kronk geht im Moment nicht ans Telefon
Ich Klingel mich woh wie schon übrigens
vor dem fragevideo irgendwann meldet er
sich aber das kann eine Weile dauern so
um ihn ein wenig dazu zu bewegen mich
bald zurückzurufen erstmal hier bitte
Kronk ruf mich an und ansonsten ihr
könnt auch was tun und zwar Video
Anworten auf dieses Video posten in
denen ihr begründet warum Gronk jetzt
möglichst bald auch das Interview mit
mir machen soll und eure nutzerfragen
beantworten soll lasst euch wie immer
was anfangen nur jetzt habt ihr absolute
Freiheit ihr könnt total kreativ sein
ihr müsst nicht im Bild sein ihr könnt
euch irgendwas überlegen haut rein ich
bin total gespannt und den Infotext
müsst auch nicht lesen aber eine
Videoantwort auf dieses Video sollte es
schon sein ich bin gespannt und ich
denke auch Gronk wird sich tierisch
freuen und mich ganz schnell anrufen bis
dann